I used Andre Carpathy's auto research to
build an automatically improving content
machine. It makes five videos per day,
publishes them, gathers real data,
figures out what worked and what didn't,
then rewrites its own prompts to get
better every single day automatically.
Let me show you how I built it, and I'll
give you the entire template for free.
But before that, just let me show you
how it works. So what is auto research?
So a couple weeks ago, Andre Karpathy,
one of the founding members of OpenAI
and former head of AI at Tesla, released
this repo that is called Auto Research.
And the idea is dead simple. You give an
AI agent three things, a file to change,
instructions on what to optimize, and a
way to measure whether it got better.
Then you just let it run. And in his
case, he was optimizing for machine
learning training scripts. So his
experiment right here, the agent would
tweak the code, run it, check if the
results improved, then kept the changes
if they did, throw them out if they
didn't, and repeat. He ran hundreds of
experiments overnight, and got an 11%
improvement. But here's what most people
miss. This isn't just for machine
learning. You can apply this to
literally anything that has a measurable
output. I looked at this and thought my
content pipeline has all three of these.
The prompt is my train.py. The loop
instructions are my program MD and the
eval is real views from Instagram and
Facebook. I built it and here's how you
can do it too. Pulling the data. So, it
all started when I posted this repo into
Claude Code and asked if it was actually
possible to use this repo with a
feedback of views taken from social
media instead because I kind of wanted
to selfoptimized based on views. After a
quick confirmation that it wouldn't be
exactly the same cuz this has a slow
loop using 24 hours as the time base, I
kind of started getting obsessed and
just had to figure out if I could do it.
So the actual work was to pull Instagram
data and Facebook data to analyze it and
start creating my eval basically what to
optimize for based on real data. I have
fully unleashed my AI avatar to
Instagram and Facebook using my AI
clone. And as you can see, most of the
views are a,000, but some actually get
over 100,000 views without me having to
film anything. And the real question
was, what are the criteria that are
basically 198 views, right? So, I set
this all up through a metagraph API,
which is completely free. I made a new
app and then I went to the tools, the
graph API explorer, added some Instagram
basic permissions and read pages and
just like that he found our 30 last
reels sorted by views as top performers
and the bottom performers as well. It
said a clear pattern already jumping
out. the wow factor visual demos crush
it where clawed code or productivity
content underperforms and I was like
that doesn't really make sense can you
actually pull a lot more data and just
like that it pulled 200 Instagram reels
and started getting even more key
patterns of what was working and what
was underperforming but because
Instagram is a bit different than
Facebook we had to pull from there as
well so we can actually sandbox it based
on just Instagram and Facebook, no other
social media platforms now that it had
all the data, but we had to build the
eval. So, this is where most people
screw up auto research. They make the
eval criteria something like, is this
engaging or does it sound good? That's
just vibes. And what we need is a clear
yes no question, no gray area. And
please roast me in the comments. I would
love for this to improve by you guys
improving it as well. But here are the e
vowels that we ended up with. This is no
vibes. It's just a yes no. Does the hook
describe a result or transformation? Not
just a feature. Does the hook feature a
person or story, not just a company?
Those are for the hook quality and the
content framing. Is the short framed
around what you can do, not what it is.
Does the script avoid sounding like a
press release or change log? Right? So,
you can see these are yes no questions
that can be answered easily. Would the
first frame of this video make someone
stop scrolling? These were the 10
questions that we ended up with. And the
key is that binary criteria are machine
readable. You can feed a script into
Gemini and ask it these 10 questions and
you get a score out of 10. No
subjectivity, no rate this on a scale of
1 to 10, just on vibes. It's just yes,
no. But now that we had all of these, we
started on wiring the loop. Here is the
actual system. I'll show you in a
minute. Here is the actual code that it
wrote. 1,000 lines, a auto research loop
that is working exactly like this. The
first thing is that we pull our views
from Facebook and Instagram. This is
really important cuz every morning maybe
we got views, maybe we didn't. Then we
match an update with views to our air
table. This is kind of our production
system. It looks like this right now.
And this is essentially where we make
all the videos. And here is where the
videos are stored as well. As you can
see, stop everything. Robots are now
mastering your favorite sports just by
watching our messy YouTube clips.
Pretty cool. And as you can see, we have
the database here for the Eval score
performance tier, etc. And the
automation in the back end, just to show
you, looks a bit like this. And AI can
improve this by itself over time. But
I'm getting ahead of myself. Next, we
prescore new ideas. So we scrape social
media every single morning. We have an
eval that is actually based on just the
sources as well. Even before creating.
So there's two sets of evals here. And
if it gets above a five score, it
answers the creation queue. Next, we
score published script. So Gemini reads
each script and answers 10 yes no eval
questions. That's the one you just saw.
And outputs a score for every published
short. Next we correlate with high eval
plus high views equal validated winners.
High eval plus low views false
positives. That means we have to fix the
eval plus handle rankings plus approval
rate tracking. As you can see it's
getting smarter. Then we generate and
push. We write an improved prompt from
correlation data winners failures. push
new prompt to nan workflow via API and
selfimprovement loop is going every 24
hours starting at 8 a.m. my time. All
fully automated with one Python script,
but you might be wondering how it
evolved. As you can see, we started with
the original prompt that had a hook,
detail, tone, close, word budget, and
etc. Then it started reframing it from
announcement to a curiosity trigger. It
pushed it to be broader, more dramatic.
Then it tried to deepen the
personalization with lifealtering
language added. The hook scoped away
from events more into universal and
timeless discoveries. And we ended up at
hoop framing sharpened with secrets
about to be revealed. So it went through
five meaningful revisions across two
days and we can see it all here in this
auto research prompt JSON that get
updated every single day based on the
criteria. But the last part I had to
figure out was how to run it daily. The
last piece is making it hands off. So
the script runs every morning at 8:00
a.m. via Launchd. So that's Mac OS's
task launcher. Every day it pulls
yesterday's views counts and it does all
these things right and at the end it
actually gives me a summary or auto auto
research daily report. Here it has the
top performers that we have done the
prompt updates with a bunch of changes
that it's done with top handles and
human approval as well. Currently I have
a team member that is using
contentmate.2.0.3
0.3 where he is using it himself
manually and we got content mate v2.1
now that has this auto improvement
feature built into it and literally
every single day five videos get made
and my coworker what he does is watch
the video and if it's good he puts this
one on schedule if it's not good he just
says no and AI learns from this as well
making it almost 100% fully automated
besides quality inspection. And the
beautiful thing is that it never stops
getting better. Every day, the pipeline
publishes five shorts. 24 hours later,
the loop checks back in what happened.
The prompts get slightly better. After a
week and seven iterations, after a
month, 30. Unlike manual tweaking, every
single change is logged with the data
that cost it. So when a smarter model
comes out next month, I hand it that
research log and it picks up exactly
where it last left off. And Karpathy
said this himself, the research log
might be the most valuable asset. And
you can apply this to anything. Your
thumbnail prompts, your email sequences,
your landing pages. If a prompt has a
measurable output, auto research can
improve it. This is the coolest thing
that I found in a long while, and I'm
giving it all away for free. If you want
Contentmate, if you want the Nan
template and you want the auto
improvement loop, head to our free
school community where I give away all
the resources here inside of the AI
clone automation. But I can understand
that it is maybe a little bit technical
for some people. So if you want to
implement this way easier, customize it
for your business, head into the AIMAT
Plus community where I will help you
more hands-on. Now I guess all we need
to do is wait. I want to make a video in
a month from now showing the exact
results and what ended up happening. So,
subscribe. Maybe it's gotten better or
it's posting corn. Who knows? But it's
going to be fun. Anyways, thanks for
watching and I'll see you tomorrow at